you can indulge in world-class dining
while giving back to the las vegas
community we're joined today by janet
lefevre who is here from the venetian
resort and kate hibbard gaines from
three square food bank uh talking about
this new digital cookbook thank you both
for being here thank you for having us
and i was just saying before we joined
uh the audience live here how much i
appreciate what three square does and
and how important it is in the community
tell us about the holidays and why this
is an important time for your group yeah
absolutely i mean three square southern
nevada's only food bank we serve four
counties out here um food insecurity is
is a big issue in our community it was
prior to the pandemic but you know
throughout that pandemic we saw record
high rates
you know today one out of six
individuals doesn't always know where
their next meal is coming from one out
of four children go home to a food
insecure household and so
partnerships like this are just
tremendous and such a great help
especially as we head into the holiday
season yeah a great time because a lot
of people are going to be in the kitchen
doing a lot of great meals and there's a
digital cookbook now that people can get
that will at the same time benefit a
great cause absolutely at grand canal
shops it was our pleasure to work with
more than 30 of our chef driven
restaurants and restaurant tours to put
together with the venetian resort this
incredible digital cookbook with over 22
recipes that have never been published
before so there's incredible favorites
from restaurants like tau asian bistro
smith and wolinski
sushi samba that for the first time ever
you can make these recipes at home with
your family and friends and do good at
the same time when you mention when you
mention the high-end restaurants like
that might be intimidating someone might
like me might think i can't i can't
match that i won't be able to do it but
this cookbook
kind of takes you through the process
pretty simply right absolutely the chefs
were just incredibly lovely they put
together together really easy recipes
and some of their best known favorites
that anybody can make these recipes
there's main dishes there's desserts
there's appetizers and of course there's
incredible cocktails that are available
inside the cookbook love it so for
people who want to get this how do they
do it head to
dot org slash e cookbook every purchase
all the proceeds are going to go
directly to three square so actually
every purchase you make is going to
provide 30 meals back into our community
which is just tremendous so you know the
numbers i mentioned earlier are pretty
staggering right the number of food and
security people and people are always
wondering how can i help what can i do
this is an incredible way to give back
and to have a little fun right it is and
a great time uh with the holidays coming
up janet and kate thank you both so much
for being here really appreciate it hope
a
lot